hello everyone and welcome to another
most exciting game from the 2019 Norway
rapid blitz championship its Magnus
Carlsen versus Wesley so and it seems
that Magnus Carlsen has took it upon
himself to play well
a funky opening against every member of
the of the championship we already saw
his game against maxime beaugeois
grabber I played b4 against that b6s
Cillian here is gonna be again a very
exciting very old-school opening against
Wesley so he played the Norwegian
defence against Fabiana Caruana
so he just well that's that's what you
do obvious when you when you world
champion but without further ado let's
get back to this game Carlson has the
white pieces and he opens with E for
with E 5 and Bishop to c4 so the bishops
opening something Carson has been known
for playing from time to time especially
when he was younger here we have Knight
to f6
and now d4 so it's a very or a very old
line it was a very popular by played by
Howard Stanton and then later after him
I was adopted by Frank James Marshall
but in modern days mostly played by
Alexandre Costa neck so here you could
go Knight captures on e4 and all our D
characters on e5 but this is not as good
for black as the line Wesley weren't for
here we have e cap for Sun b4 and now
cousin proceeds with Knight to f3 e5
isn't hold that red because after a 5
you can just go d5 and black is
perfectly fine so after you capture Sun
before we have Knight to f3 and now
comes Knight to c6 with E 5 now across
and now d5 with Bishop to b5 and now
Knight to e4 so we basically transfer
transposed into the two Knights defense
of the of the Italian with Knight
captures on d4 now comes the Bishop to
c5 and here Bishop to e3 defending and
here we have just castles by Wesley
Carson characters on c6 as the knight is
no longer pinned with Bishop captures B
captures and now Knight captures and c6
is a pretty big mistake but it's
interesting to mention that it was
played in tournament games
this move is available six times in the
database but even though it seems like
it's a nice in-between move for white
because
black queen is under attack black can
just ignore that and play Bishop
captures on e3 and here after night
capture sandy eight you played this will
capture sin f2 and now King e2 is really
bad but after King f1 just Bishop to a6
and you will you will win back the Queen
so the King has nowhere to go after the
Queen blocks Queen d3 you will capture
the Queen and after C captures now you
will go Bishop to b4 it's a very nice
forced line attack the b2 point here you
want to win the rook
so after Knight to c3 you'll just go
rook after sandy eight and now you get D
captures on e4 d captures on e4 and now
Knight captures on e4 Bishop will
capture and b2 you will have to move the
rook rook e1 Bishop captures here and at
the end of this very nice forcing line
will get this position where black is up
two points in in a much better position
so all in all should be winning and out
of the six games that are available in
the database black one five one in in
one of them white managed to get a draw
but here of course Carson is not
interested in going for this he castles
here and now virtual characters on d4 we
have Queen Catherine before and now c5
pushing cross since Queen back winter d3
and now brush up to f5 and here Carson
doesn't want his Queen to remain on d3
at you know be available for all sorts
of nasty discoveries the knight can go
to g3 to or who knows where sorry about
that
so sorry sorry about that no idea how
that happened but after this after this
Bishop to a5 move I simply went had some
15 moves but after this Bishop to a5
move course and simply retreat its Queen
to e2 but it's interesting this position
has been reached before
in the 1988 Belgrade championship
between Robert Zoellick
and the sweaters are ugly garage and in
that game Bishop captures and c5 was
played which is the strongest move
recommended by the engine but that was a
classical game so the rock is under
attack you have to move the rook and
then you will normally just continue the
game
but here in the Blitz game Carson
doesn't want to have his Queen on this
day I can also he just moves it with
Queen to e2 and now comes d4 pushing the
best row back and here again this
position
position has been reached in 1967 Soviet
championship between Navi Nietzsche and
the North Cove and here
Bishop to f4 was played and the black
was able to win that game but here cross
and goes for f3 and now this is a new
move so as of now as we move thirteen we
have a completely new game on our hands
so what do you do here obviously trading
doesn't really favor black if you
capture capture and capture white can
just develop the knight Knight c3 play
the rook to d1 captured upon an e3 and
it's it's gonna be a nice position for
white so after this f3 move Wesley just
moves the knight back with Knight to g5
Bishop captures on g5 wouldn't attack on
the Queen Queen captures and g5 and now
you can develop the Knights to d2
because you will lose the seat upon
which would be very dangerous
it would create a past deep on so Carson
is a force to develop the knight in a
different fashion he goes Knights to a
three and now rook F the e8 now the idea
is bring this rook over to DA to go d5
attack this pawn maybe even f6 will be
an idea I will see depending on what
caused some plays of course we have rook
81 and now rook a to d8 Wesley simply
continues with this plan and here
Crossan doesn't like f4 f4 nicely guards
the pawn and attacks the Queen but it
does somewhat further weaken the Kings
side so he refrains from it he first
place rook to f2 and ice move bringing
yet another defender to the g2 pawn and
also if something like when g6 then the
c2 point is also protected one more time
here we've looked d5 attacking the e5
pawn and here again Carson doesn't like
f4 f4 is a nice move protects here
attacks the Queen so you would either
see Queen g6 or some like Queen to d8
but instead of this f4 move Carlsen goes
Queen to b5 seems like a nice in-between
move you get out of this nasty pin on
the e-file also it comes with an attack
on the rook here but it simply doesn't
work here
white has a problem so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the the
absolute best move for forward so in
this position I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to find the correct answer you were an
excellent attacker of the Queen with the
bishop and for those of you who just
wanna enjoy the show
Bishop to d7 and now you see the problem
the bishop now forces the Queen to move
back as the rogue defends the Bishop end
now the e5 point is attacked three times
we will not be able to defend it and it
is a very important point so here at
Carson has to move with Queen to a5
and now comes Luke d captures on e5
already threatening to capture on e1 so
rook eat the f1 and now Wesley is not
really interested in guarding his C pawn
he now goes into the attack we have
looked to eat too so what do you do here
we have Queen captures on c7 by Carson
hoping to maybe bring the Queen over to
g3 maybe to help out with the defense
also the pin from c7 guards f4 so maybe
pawn to f4 also an idea but here Wesley
doesn't give him a chance to breathe he
plays rook captures an f2 and now if you
capture with the rook it's over just
rook e1 check roblox Queen III check
King has to move and then recap for C
will be checkmate so you have to capture
with the King here and that's a bit of
an issue here at Crossin captured team
captures an f2 and Wesley played Queen
to e3 check so what do you do here
Carlson played King to g3 and here was
the repeat at Queen to g5 check with
Kings - f - Queen - III check King to g3
and here after Queen to g5 it was in
this position that Wesley saw and Magnus
Carlsen agreed to a draw problem is
Wesley is completely winning in this
position but on the other hand he has
some five seconds on the clock at across
ins 50 I believe and he didn't manage to
find the correct line to beat Magnus
Carlsen from this position but you have
all the time in the world well not all
but you have time to pause the video so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the line that was missed
here so King to have to was played it
and then this was the position where
they agree to a draw but yeah try to
pause the video and find the correct
line here I'll give you a couple of
seconds as usual for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations you
are an excellent pusher of pawns and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show the problem is the correct move and
which will soon be revealed if you you
have to deal with your bishop being
attacked and the problem is if you play
something like Bishop to e6 rook e1 and
white doesn't really have all that many
problems now the bishop is pinned you
can go Knights e4 you can bring the
knight
into the game if the best moves of
course rook captures rook is the idea
and it's not not a pleasant position
anymore I mean it's still Pleasant for
black but not as pleasant for a blitz
game
so here the move you had to find is
actually d3 so being an excellent pusher
of pawns that you are you probably saw
that and now if Queen captures Bishop
now the e2 square is guarded so just
lucky to check King g1 Queen captures
and g2 will be checkmate and every other
line is also winning for blacks so what
other ways are there to defend for
example the queen is not there for
example if you try to get out of this
idea by playing g4 it still won't work
now you play d2 and now it's a again
very very nice line the Queen h4 check
now is the idea and whatever you play
let's say you capture here again just
Queen h4 check King will have to move
and now rook d8 the Queen guards the
rook the rook regards the queening
square so everything is nicely connected
whatever you do you will either move the
Queen and then d1 comes which will of
course end inmate as what black will
have two queens or you will capture here
black will capture back and again you
have a queen against a knight and rook
and also you were threatening to bring
another Queen into the game are
completely winning position and on the
other hand after this very nice d3 move
what else can you do instead of let's
say grabbing this and playing g4 you
might throw you might try something like
I don't know you might try something
like f4 but still the again the idea is
the same just rookie to check you
haven't really prevented anything Queen
g2 captures so not an option
so after d3 white does not have a good
reply so whatever you play your you're
either getting checkmate it or you will
suffer severe material loss if Queen g3
also Queen Queen III is mate in one
g2 and f1 are covered so you know it's
just a wonderful position to draw as you
are completely lost but you know it's
it's how it is
you always have to manage your time
correctly you can't allow yourself to
you know be brought down to five seconds
like Wesley did here and he did not just
didn't have enough time to finish this
game as he should have as he have he has
a you know played better than Magnus
but yeah that's also something but I am
as they say you know fortune favors the
brave the strong the the bald
the what not so here crossing again
escapes you know the jaws of death by in
a seemingly unplayable position but it
is playable due to due to a severe time
trouble by Wesley so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it and further ado
who perhaps haven't seen the previous
video I will show the standings one more
time here here here are the standings
maxime beaugeois grow one with seven and
a half points a point and a half ahead
of 11 are in Magnus cross and then with
five we have shocker momma Dee are off
wait four and a half ding lehrerin you
yongi and Wesley so with three and a
half and then with three points Fabiano
Caruana which are not around and
alexander leadership so here i don't
know if i will be showing any more games
from the Blitz event but maybe i will
will see as the classical is starting
now so I do have to prepare for that but
if you have any of your own favorites do
use hash tag suggestion and I will of
course check it out and and maybe if we
find the time we show that one as well
sure I would like I would like to thank
dr. Pollard I'm skin crispy car that was
silly care of and island Zapata for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some more
interesting content and for the do who
are interested we are still going over
your manga suggestions and I will keep
you updated as soon as we have a
definitive answer yeah I think I will
see you soon have an excellent rest of
your day and don't forget to enjoy the
live coverage of the of the Norway
classical event see you soon